The universe is a tremendous structure,
comprised of an infinite multitude of all sorts of diverse objects.
They lie so far apart in endless expansive space that even light gets
lost in their depths.
It takes a photo on traveling from the sun over four years to reach our nearest
star as for covering intergalactic distances.
It takes millions of years.
When you realize that all this enormous distance is just a tiny molecule on the
scale of macro cosmos it can't, but maze.
So what is the real size of the universe
CMO? The first outer space,
the solar system is just one of the countless multitude of planetary systems
scattered across our galaxy. As we know,
it consists of a single star is made sequence stage and date planets with our
satellites. In addition,
our system contains over a million small celestial bodies like asteroids,
comets, and meteoroids the planet and the Sola system lying furthest,
at least that we know of is Neptune its orbits radius measures
around 30 astronomical units,
which is equivalent to approximately four lighter hours.
Amazingly only a tiny portion of the Sola system is encompassed by Neptune
orbit.
The remotes object in the system discovered to date is the so-called far,
far out lying 132 astronomical units or 18 light tower
away from the sun. Still,
even this object bar visible against a dark background of unfathomable
space is not at all close to the hypothetical or cloud who's in a boundary
is lie,
approximately 2000 astronomical units away from the center of our system.
According to some estimates,
it's out boundaries stretch for up to 60,000 astronomical units.
And the very released, which is around one light year.
These limits are predefined by the sun's gravitational influence.
And what lies beyond is enter Stella space
moving further away.
We will notice over 50 of all kinds of stars within 20 light years from the sun.
These stars are really diverse from dim and cold brown wolves
to bright and widely known objects like Sirion and dag.
Some of them have their own planetary systems with objects,
potentially capable of nursing and sustaining life. For example,
the object known as Gleesa a three, two C,
which is 16.1 light years away from the sun is similar to our earth
more than any other planet within the solar system that we know of the
average temperature on the Axo planet surface reaches to 153 Calvin
or 20 degrees celss below zero,
and it takes the astronomical body just 36 earth days to complete a full
orbit around its parent star in astronomical standards.
The distance between us and glee, a three, two C is relatively small.
However,
a space probe setting out from our system at a speed of roughly 17 kilometers
per second,
would take as much as 300,000 years to reach the exoplanets environs
at our current level of technological advancement,
it is impossible to design an inter Stella spaceship capable of completing as
long a journey as that
the solar system together with its neighbor stars is part of the ion arm.
The latter in its turn is part of the Milky way.
It contains around 400 billion stars and potentially over a trillion
exoplanets of all sorts can be discovered there. According to estimates today,
the main diameter of the Milky way measures around a hundred thousand light
years. And the stellar halo may be twice as large,
even though the thickness of the main disc measures about a thousand light
years, there is a clearly defined bulge in the galaxy center.
This bulge is roughly 3000 years thick.
The Milky way is part of the so-called local group.
This is a vast structure comprising over 50 galaxies,
concentrated within an area of space measuring around 10 million light years in
diameter. The ter galaxy,
the triangular galaxy and the Milky way are the largest of the law art.
Some estimates show that the mass total of the cluster may reach as much as 3
trillion solar masses with our galaxy and aro accounting for the major part
with the distance from the earth turned Dramat around 2.5 million light years.
It is considered to be our closest galaxy, not counting smaller or dwarf ones
moving on to the next order.
The local group forms part of the giant Virgo super cluster made up of over
30,000 galaxies.
The super cluster is located within an area of space with a diameter of around
115 million light years.
Its must total is as much as a quadrillion solar masses or in other words,
around a thousand galaxies Lu the Milky way.
The super cluster is quite flattened and around 60% of all the objects it
is made up of appear like a flat sheet around 10 million light years thick
staggering, though it may appear on the fake of it.
This value is actually small in terms of the large scale structure of the
universe. As we zoom out still more,
we have a chance of seeing a giant super cluster of galaxies,
approximately 520 million light years in size
cord Laia Kia. It includes several galaxy, super clusters among others,
the Virgo super cluster and the great tractor.
The overall mass of this formation measures,
approximately as much as a hundred quadrillion solar masses,
the greater tractor lies roughly to hundred and 50 million light years away from
our planet and is the gravitational center for all objects flying close by
astronomical standards.
It cannot be observed from the earth directly as the Milky way's plane towards
it. That is by the nature of the great attract.
Still remains an unsolved mystery today.
Laia Kea is part of the large scale structure of the universe,
an elaborate system of gala galactic filaments walls and voids,
Gargan areas of emptiness and space.
Some of these objects are really incredibly enormous. For example,
the, the Hercules Corona Borealis, great wall used for round of staggering,
10 billion light years ever since its discovery in 2013,
this super structure has been considered the most gigantic component of the
large scale structure of the universe to all appearances.
It must be home to millions of galaxies and the number of stars it contains will
probably all ways defy calculation,
the mere existence of a structure like that is a mystery to science as according
to today's accepted theory of universes, evolution, Gargan,
and clusters like that are simply not supposed to form, but incidentally,
this wall so enormous that the human brain cannot fully appreciate.
Its is still just a tiny portion of the observable universe.
According to today's cosmological notions space.
And the universe is continually expanding with the speed of expansion,
depending on the distance between objects,
the further and observed object lies away from the observer.
The faster the distance between in the two increases the rate at which the two
mutually recede is not limited by the speed of light,
because it's actually space matter. That is expanding,
which means that at a certain point,
the two objects will be mutually unobservable Relic.
Radiation observation shows that the area of the observable universe is a sphere
with a diameter roughly 93 billion light years.
According to the theory of relativity,
we can see and interact with only those objects that are within this sphere.
This conventional spherical area in space is called the meta galaxy.
And it may be either all of the universe or again, its tiny portion
for all we know, hypothetically there may well lie,
some unknown structures beyond the visible boundaries of space.
Such entities are referred to as extra lactic objects.
And unfortunately it is impossible to study them today with scientific methods,
still some astronomical bodies on the edge of the visible universe appear to be
moving in ways different from what we would naturally expect judging by the data
we have instances of anomalous movements.
Like those may be evidence of the presence of some massive struck is beyond the
meta galaxy boundaries,
their attraction pervades the space around and influences objects around two.
There is a whole plethora of hypotheses as to the structure of the universe,
beyond the meta galaxy. But most of them are rather of metaphysical nature.
For example,
some people believe that time and space as we more or less know them are
nonexistent beyond the boundaries of the universe.
The physical laws were used to did not apply there either.
And notions of matter material or energy are virtually senseless.
This hypothesis is further elaborated on by the following idea,
the matter galaxy accounts for just a part of a yet more complex and larger
scale,
super structure in space whose makeup and dimensions are too incredible for us
to imagine it is quite possible that this structure could be in a
multidimensional space or else be based on physical principles.
We have no idea of this makes the matter galaxy just insignificant
addition to, or a part reflection of this mind, boggling super structure.
According to some interpretations of the anthropic principle,
there are other worlds out there beyond the boundaries of the observable
universe in those worlds,
the values of the fundamental constants like the speed of light or the electron
charge are completely different.
This high hypothesis is in many ways supported by the idea of a multiverse,
which schematically appears as foam with lots of bubbles separated from each
other by thin balls.
But these walls are impenetrable. This makes every universe,
a separate space with its own physical laws.
And for all we know these laws be totally different from the ones we are used to
the most radical hypotheses go as far to deny our world any objective
reality whatsoever.
According to these,
the universe is just a simulation like virtual reality and computers,
but on an incredibly advanced level,
as a rule ideas like that implied that there is some super beings or
super civilizations out there beyond the reality we're used to whose level of
advancement is infinitely higher than ours and whose goals and capabilities
are arcane and incomprehensible. However,
it goes without saying that it is hardly possible to either confirm or purate
these hypotheses
of course, distances in space,
defy our imagination and are even frightening.
They appear infinite from the point of view of any person today.
What we do know is that the universe is expanding and provided this process
continues.
There will come a point when space objects will disappear one after another,
beyond the event,
horizon first galaxies then stars and the world will
immerse in eternal.
But by then there will be no one around to witness that